[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh reggie miller he lives in the water
in malibu
uh hall of famer there have you seen
sharks there do you what's your
water policy reg uh until a shark
actually
walks on land and takes a bite out of me
i'm not gonna go into his territory and
i agree
with with uh fritzy
i wonder if the shark actually knows if
it's an axle dinner
tip over from the boat or hey let's get
these cool
instagram pictures with this great white
shark because the shark would be like
are you
serious you want instagram pictures all
right come a little bit closer
come here come here wait but you live in
malibu but you don't go in the water
no number one is too cold
and no i i that's a whole
another world i don't now a lot of
people have tried
laird hamilton took me paddle boarding
once and i was
i feared for my life i feared for my
life
because he's like the real life aquaman
he can do you know he speaks to dolphins
and sharks and trails and all that
and he's like hey paddle like this and
just breathe and you feel with one of
the nation and i'm like trying to hold
on for dear life like
the balance and all that and he's just
like oh this he's doing it with one foot
out he's holding it the [ __ ]
i'm like dude get me back to land but
you're always on your mountain bike have
you ever
encountered any animals
other than rattlesnakes and one mountain
lion
but i saw the mountain lion from a
distance and turned around quickly
very quickly but you always hop
rattlesnakes all the time you're always
hopping rattlesnakes
yeah but you don't look like a meal to a
mountain lion though reg
you don't think i would no
no i don't think i don't think i think i
would be a delicious six seven meal
for a mountain lion if you're gonna ride
i'd ride next to oliver miller
oh that's the miller time yeah
yeah oliver miller
um the usa lost to nigeria
in a friendly basketball game is this a
big deal reg for our olympic team
i'm not ready to jump off the cliff
quite yet it's only alarming because
when the team was assembled i
i looked at the roster and the first
thing i said to myself there's not a lot
of size yeah
yeah and well isn't draymond a center
him and bam i i guess are the centers on
this team they have a lot of wing
players a lot of guard play
again that's the way the game is
trending towards
but i i look at i don't know what bigs
we really could have
added for for size most of the true big
men are international players
joel embiid jokic even deandre ayton
who's playing fantastic
for phoenix in the series is from the
bahamas so
i don't know if we really had a lot of
size i'm not that alarmed
nigeria i mean wait
what happens when you play france or
spain
or argentina teams that are
well versed in international play
i i've got to see a little bit more even
australia i know they have an exhibition
game with australia coming up
australia has some nba players and
talent so
we'll just have to wait and see well we
had michael wilbon on in the first hour
and he said the all-star game should be
the u.s
against the world and and there would be
true pride there certainly for the world
to try to beat the united states
you could build a pre you could have a
pretty good roster
of the world versus the u.s what do you
think of that idea
i love it and i think at some point i
think it's trending
that way and i think um adam silver
has looked into that um i think it would
be fantastic
and it's almost safe to say we may be
the underdogs
i'm not saying you wouldn't win but we
very well could be the underdogs if
if that game was to shape out with
today's players
because they would certainly have the
size i know we would have lebron and
katie harden kyrie steph i mean we would
be loaded but so would they
they'd have some big men that's for sure
you throw in luca in there as well
you got players from canada i mean you
could
you could build a pretty good roster but
i'd love that it would mean
something because i think when we watch
and it's you know
just up and down it's a an and one game
where you're just having fun and dunking
which if if that's what fans want then
i'm fine with that the fans should
have just you know be able to decide
this
what they want to watch but i think you
could get that us against them that
pride
a little bit unless the commissioner
doesn't want it to be divisive where it
it feels like we're pitting you know us
against them and there is
some kind of separation why not why not
bring out some juices though oh i know
i'm not bringing out that competitive
spirit um i'm sure there's trash talking
that goes on
with guys you know between jamal murray
who's canadian he would probably be on
that world team yeah
along with jokage i mean why not
you know have some some competitive
spirit going on
i think it would be great when the suns
went up 2-0
you thought they did what they had to do
they held home court did you think it
was over
no okay because milwaukee plays
obviously very well at home
two things though that have emerged to
be very clear in this series
number one they have zero answer for
giannis antetokounmpo
whether it's d'andrea ayton and his size
trying to guard him
they downgraded and uh
put jay crowder on him mikhail bridges
it doesn't matter
his size his offensive rebounding and
now that he's
starting to hit free throws last night
was his his
best uh trek to the free-throw line they
have no answer for him
and number two when chris middleton and
drew holiday
play reasonable their
this milwaukee bucks team is very
difficult to beat
but when phoenix went up to nothing they
did what they had to do they held home
court
now milwaukee is one game away from
doing the same thing at some point in
time
milwaukee obviously has to win a road
game to win an nba championship
i was more impressed that they put
something on the mind of phoenix now
because they blew them out and it was i
mean they just ran them out the gym
especially in that third quarter
so game four we'll see if
devin booker is not going to score 10
points and shoot that terrible so
he'll have a balance back game but game
four is everything that will tell me
everything about this series
i still watch giannis and i was talking
to wilbon about this
that why can't i just have him do
what he's great at doing not not the
other stuff
where he's he's not even good at taking
three-point shots
and i don't want him dribbling the ball
up the floor if he dribbles up the floor
i can build a wall there
if i put him down low now you got to
decide you want to double him
and that's where i got lopez holliday
and chris middleton
and it's uh it's incumbent upon them to
hit those shots
but you can't guard the greek freak down
low with one person
and and i can get you in foul trouble
he's going to get to the hoop
that's that's what i want you know shaq
i never said boy you've got to hit some
jumpers
or you know kareem you got to come out
to uh
the free throw line like i never said
any i just thought man
that's they're unstoppable that's what i
want them to continue to do
why is it that mike budenholzer still
has the greek freak out on the perimeter
well i i will say this i wouldn't take
away him not bringing the ball up
because
in the open court when he gets ahead of
steam very difficult to stop especially
with that euro step so you don't want to
take away
that part i'm okay in transition reg
okay
absolutely okay i i will say
the thing about the three-point shots
and it kills me you and i have talked
about this
for the last two months during the
playoffs
if he's going to settle for threes
they're going to lose they're going to
lose the nba championship
to me their dare shots
that teams give him make up the
difference i don't care if they're
giving me dear shots
make up the difference and then go into
what you're alluding to
the spin move one dribble and you're at
the rim or you're finding
your shooters and we saw that
really in these first three games
versus phoenix i think in game one
he wasn't sure he was still worried
about the hyper extension
of the knee he he wasn't playing the
game instinctual
which people aren't factoring in what
he's been able to do with
an injury that i had channing frye told
me he said i had the same thing
i don't think he plays again i he said
it took me six weeks to recover from
that
greek creek you know he
he men's remarkable and
how he's finishing too because the moves
are crisp
they're clean they're decisive
and you're right it monty williams is
gonna have to make a decision of
doubling but when you double
coach buttenholzer loves they love the
three ball they average 43 is the game
they haven't shot them great yeah
but they love shooting them and at some
point in time
they're going to start making them damn
and if you're phoenix the problem is
this series ends up 2-2 game five on the
road
it's one of those games where you think
everything is going to start clicking
for
milwaukee i still like phoenix i had
phoenix winning in seven
but i think this is going to go the
distance i think milwaukee wins tomorrow
and again no all phoenix has to do is
win home games and they win it all
so i think it's a seven game series it's
gonna go the distance
both of these teams are well matched but
zero
answer for giannis and if holliday and
if middleton
contributes a little bit then milwaukee
will win the championship
i was talking to wilbon about this as
well that you know we look at the lakers
and somehow we want to always put the
best player on the lakers like lebron's
gonna get
uh damien lillard and then i always say
but who's
portland getting in return and
you know wilbon said you know you're
right but there's this would you trade
anthony davis for damian lillard
if you were the leader no
no absolutely not as as much as i love
uh damian lillard lillard has to have
the ball in his hands to be successful
that's what made him great great
isolation one-on-one
high pick-and-roll player for lebron
what he's done throughout his career
needs the ball to be successful i don't
think they would play well off of one
another i just don't
and i think that's why anthony davis is
a perfect compliment
if you can stay healthy i know do lebron
okay so then if you're the lakers i will
say this you know who would be better on
that team
cj mccollum yeah would be great on the
lakers
with lebron okay so how do you get him
do you do a
signing trade with dennis schroeder
yes i would get rid of schroeder and i
would possibly think about getting rid
of
cow i got
no problem tucker i like i like him
i would i would break caruso out of jail
in texas
and yeah i would get rid of schroeder
and kuzma for cj mccollum
i would i think he would be perfect for
the lakers
i don't know if kuzma wants to be great
like you can get caught up in the
trappings of being in hollywood and we
talked about this
with the younger guys when lebron one of
those guys out like you kind of get
caught up in i'm a laker in the
lifestyle
and you know like i don't i don't sense
that from
caruso no not caruso kuzma
oh yeah i think he's connor
you know you got your hair blonde and
you know you're dating a kardashian or
something and
i think he as much as i like i love kyle
his rookie year i thought he played
fantastic yes he got
i think he got caught up yeah got up in
the lifestyle
now he has a ring but it felt like
an ingram needed to get out because of
his personality and
and even you know lonzo ball like the
personality sometimes you wonder
like you got to be ready for l.a
and you know and i wonder some of these
what you've seen like could tim duncan
other than san antonio like they've just
felt like that's where tim duncan was
supposed to be
or david robin like there's certain guys
you just go their personality fits that
city and vice versa
i agree and
look kyle kuzma is a great player
he thinks he could be a double-double
type guy i'm not saying he can't
but he had plenty of opportunity
to be really an nba type
player when lebron was gone for those 30
something games as well as a.d
he had a chance yeah he really had an
opportunity and he didn't deliver
i'm not saying he can't but you had an
opportunity but lebron can stunt your
growth too because
you're not quite sure what am i allowed
to do
[Music]
i mean not to the extent like with
michael jordan but
you know when when you're there with
lebron it's it's like
how do i know it's called expectations
he can't raise his expectations playing
with a long
a generational type player no
lebron lebron elevates god think about
some of the teams that lebron took to
the finals in cleveland
like where are these guys now so he's
not stunning kyle kuzma
booby gibson was a starting point on him
come on man
did he stun eric snow
come on man no uh did you hear jamal
mashburn's story about
larry bird no he he was
they were um this is when the college
guys were playing against the dream team
so it's weber and rodney rogers and and
mash was telling the story that
rodney rogers has given bird grief
you know that you know you haven't been
anything since 1984.
and and this is after i think they beat
them in one of the scrimmages
and they were first right yeah and and
and so berber checks into the game in
the next one
and mashburn was telling the story that
rodney rogers was guarding him
and magic gave him the ball like eight
times in a row
and larry is telling him where he's
going to shoot
and then i think he made the last one he
goes yeah just like 1984.
and whoever said chris webber said it
was an assassination of rodney rogers
and you know rodney loved to talk
but when hearing mashburn tell the story
it was really funny
you know that's what hey that's larry
and his finest because not only was he
doing that against you know
rogers who at the time was a you know a
college player
he was doing that to chuck person during
a playoff game i'm gonna i'm gonna go
here i'm gonna shoot this shot i'm gonna
fade away i'm gonna make it with my
laugh
next time i come down i'm gonna do it i
just watch my footwork
chuck hey chuck watch my footwork now
okay
and then whoever said that bird would
get mad
whenever there was a white guy guarding
him like he would get so mad
but there's not a white guy on on the
planet and guard me
and he would get so angry when somebody
like marley when dan marley
i think he wouldn't he wouldn't talk to
dan marley
because he was a rookie refused to talk
to dan marley and he would talk to
like andrew langer somebody and say you
send the message to dan marley he said
that he wouldn't he wouldn't and marley
said he wouldn't talk to me because i
was a rookie i love
it yeah um let's see so you got the sons
in
seven all right all right not bad
what do you think i think chris paul
devin booker
other than last night because chris paul
played pretty well in the first half
i i think the guard play has been
fantastic for phoenix
and booker is not going to shoot that
bad score 10 points i think he'll have a
bounce back game
but until they find an answer for that
greek freak they won't have an answer
for them
they don't if they have to have answers
for holiday and middleton
that those guys can't get off and if
they do
with the greek freak doing what he does
i mean he's
these are oh by the way 40 40 10 rebound
games
and easy too easy i know i mean he's
getting them
everything is just about in the paint
but you're right
because of the inconsistency of
middletown
and holiday which we've seen if they
can't be consistent
phoenix is going to win this series if
they're consistent
milwaukee can come back and win this in
winning one on the road
thank you reg great to talk to you
theodore i love you
i love my dad hey sorry give well wishes
to your brother man i mean fly fishing
who knew that was such a
a combat sport man i know
i know i put the fly in fly fishing okay
i mean next time you pad up
a helmet we were gonna buy
my brother a helmet that you give to a
little kid when they're first learning
to ride a bike just so yeah
he'd go fly fishing casey flew out of
the boat again
thank you reg you're the best theodore
all right we'll take a break last call
for phone calls what we learn
what's in store tomorrow after this